You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够让我们迷失方向了！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Body-focused repetitive behaviors like trichotillomania or chronic hair pulling, as well as skin picking, nail biting, and others may affect up to 1 and 20 people. Yet, despite how common they are, BFRBs, as they're called, remain stigmatized, misunderstood, and underdiagnosed.
希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要的是优惠，而不是惊喜时。住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为你而住。以身体为中心的重复性行为，如拔毛癖或慢性拔毛，以及抠皮、咬指甲等，可能影响多达 1/20 的人。然而，尽管它们很常见，但这些所谓的 BFRB 仍然受到污名化、误解和诊断不足。
Today we're going to talk with two experts about why that is and about how our understanding of BFRBs has evolved in recent years. So what are body-focused repetitive behaviors? How do they differ from ordinary habits? When and why do they start and why are they so hard to stop? How does living with trichotillomania or another BFRB affect people's lives and their mental health? What kinds of treatments and therapies can help? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
今天我们将与两位专家探讨其中的原因，以及近年来我们对 BFRB 的理解是如何演变的。那么，什么是以身体为中心的重复性行为？它们与普通习惯有何不同？它们何时开始，为何开始，又为何如此难以停止？患有拔毛癖或其他 BFRB 如何影响人们的生活和心理健康？什么样的治疗和疗法可以提供帮助？欢迎收听《心理学对话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Suzanne Muton-Odom, a clinical assistant professor of psychology at the Baylor College of Medicine, and the founder and director of Psychology Houston, the Center for Cognitive Behavioral Treatment. She specializes in treating people with body-focused repetitive behaviors, as well as obsessive compulsive disorder, tick disorders, and other anxiety disorders. Dr. Muton-Odom is co-chair of the board. Board of Directors and the Scientific Advisory Board of the TLC Foundation for Body-focused
我是金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。第一位是贝勒医学院心理学临床助理教授、休斯顿心理学认知行为治疗中心创始人兼主任苏珊·穆顿-奥多姆博士。她专门治疗患有以身体为中心的重复性行为、强迫症、抽动症和其他焦虑症的患者。穆顿-奥多姆博士是 TLC 以身体为中心重复性行为基金会董事会和科学顾问委员会的联合主席。
repetitive behaviors. She has published many scientific journal articles and has co-authored six books, including A Parent Guide to Hair Pulling Disorder and the BFRB Survival Guide, a workbook for Overcoming Body-Focused Repetitive Behaviors. Our second guest is Dr. Claire McKay, a professor of neuroscience at Oxford University in the UK, where she heads the translational neuroimaging group. Most of Dr. McKay's research focuses on using neuroimaging to understand risk for diseases such as Parkinson's and Alzheimer's. In recent years, she's begun studying the neuroscience of body-focused repetitive behaviors
她发表了许多科学期刊文章，并合著了六本书，包括《拔毛障碍家长指南》和《BFRB 生存指南：克服以身体为中心重复性行为的工作手册》。我们的第二位嘉宾是英国牛津大学神经科学教授克莱尔·麦凯博士，她负责转化神经影像小组。麦凯博士的大部分研究集中于利用神经影像学来了解帕金森病和阿尔茨海默病等疾病的风险。近年来，她开始研究以身体为中心重复性行为的神经科学，
were spurred by her own experience dealing with trichotillomania since childhood. She's author of the forthcoming book, Keep Your Hair on, Understanding Urges to Pick, Pull, or Bite, which will be published in April 2006. Dr. Moutanodum, Dr. McKay, thank you both for joining me today. Thank you for having us. Thank you so much. Let's start by explaining in a little more detail, body-focused, repetitive behaviors.
这源于她自己从小应对拔毛癖的经历。她是即将出版的新书《保持你的头发：理解抠、拔或咬的冲动》的作者，该书将于 2006 年 4 月出版。穆顿-奥多姆博士、麦凯博士，感谢你们今天加入我的节目。谢谢邀请我们。非常感谢。让我们先详细解释一下以身体为中心的重复性行为。
What exactly are they? How many different types are they? What is the term encompass? That's a great question. So the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders describes BFRBs as hair pulling or skin picking. You know, as you pointed out, trichitaomania is the technical word for hair pulling disorder. Excoriation disorder is the technical term for skin picking disorder.
它们到底是什么？有多少种不同的类型？这个术语涵盖了什么？这是一个很好的问题。精神疾病诊断与统计手册将 BFRB 描述为拔毛或抠皮。如你所指出的，拔毛癖是拔毛障碍的专业术语。皮肤抓挠障碍是抠皮障碍的专业术语。
Hair pulling disorder can encompass any hair on the body. You know, eyelashes, eyebrows, pubic hair, arm hair, facial hair, leg hair, any hair. Most commonly, it's scalp, eyelashes, and eyebrows. And really it's that you've tried to stop and you're not able to stop and it causes some problem for you in your life. So it's a pretty general definition. And we used to have some other qualifications or criteria that we're needing to be met. But in the latest iteration, that's pretty much it. And it's not accounted for by, say, alopecia or some dermatological disorder.
拔毛障碍可以涵盖身体上的任何毛发。睫毛、眉毛、阴毛、手臂毛、面部毛发、腿毛，任何毛发。最常见的是头皮、睫毛和眉毛。关键在于你尝试过停止但无法停止，并且它在生活中给你造成了一些问题。所以这是一个相当笼统的定义。我们过去有一些其他的限定条件或标准，但在最新版本中，基本上就是这样。而且它不能用脱发症或某种皮肤病来解释。
Skin picking disorder is pretty much the same. It involves repetitive picking of one skin to the point where it causes a lot. a problem and a person feels like they're not able to stop. And again, it's not accounted for by a dermatological condition or some other psychiatric diagnosis. How do these behaviors differ from what we might just consider a bad habit, like nail biting? Dr. McKay, what are your thoughts on that? Well, I don't think they're different at all from nail biting. Naill biting is another type of body-focused repetitive behavior. And it's actually the one that's kind of most socially acceptable. So the way that I think about BFRBs is that they are all
抠皮障碍也差不多。它涉及重复地抠自己的皮肤，直到造成很大的问题，且当事人觉得无法停止。同样，它不能用皮肤病或其他精神诊断来解释。这些行为与我们可能认为的坏习惯（如咬指甲）有何不同？麦凯博士，你对此有何看法？嗯，我不认为它们与咬指甲有什么不同。咬指甲是另一种以身体为中心的重复性行为。而且它实际上是社会接受度最高的一种。所以我对 BFRB 的看法是，它们都是
of the picking and pulling and biting of hair and skin and nails. And of course, we all do these things a bit because they are normal grooming behaviours. And as Suzanne said, it's only hair pulling and skin picking that have made it into the DSM. But really anybody who has BFRBs that cause them significant amounts of distress and are impacting the way that people, can live their normal lives are in the same category as far as I understand it. There is, the behaviors are not really different. I bite my nails too. I pull my hair and I bite my nails and as far as I'm concerned, they're the same. Yeah. Is there any relationship to cutting? So that's a great question and it comes up a lot. You know, intentional harm to one's body.
抠、拔、咬头发、皮肤和指甲的行为。当然，我们都会做这些事，因为它们是正常的梳理行为。正如苏珊所说，只有拔毛和抠皮进入了 DSM。但据我所知，任何患有 BFRB 并因此感到严重困扰、影响正常生活的人，都属于同一类别。这些行为并没有什么不同。我也咬指甲。我拔头发也咬指甲，在我看来，它们是一样的。是的。这与自残有关系吗？这是一个很好的问题，经常被问到。
I guess one could think about these because on the surface they kind of look like there might be self-damaging, self-harming behaviors, but really it's quite different. We see the function of a BFRB as more self-regulation, self-soothing, or serving some sort of a function to the person, the function not being self-harm. People oftentimes are even trying to fix a problem or to improve a situation by removing all of a certain type of hair or removing a bump. And so the function is quite different than in a self-mutilation or self-harming type behavior. So we treat them very differently and we think about them very differently. I talked in my intro about prevalence, but what does the research say about how common BFRBs are?
我想人们可能会这样想，因为从表面上看，它们看起来像是自残行为，但实际上却大不相同。我们将 BFRB 的功能视为更多的自我调节、自我安抚，或者为个人服务某种功能，而不是自残。人们往往甚至试图通过去除某种类型的毛发或去除肿块来解决问题或改善状况。因此，其功能与自残行为完全不同。所以我们对它们的治疗方式和思考方式也非常不同。我在开场白中谈到了患病率，但研究对于 BFRB 的普遍程度有何说法？
Do we have good numbers? We don't have great numbers. We have some numbers. But unfortunately, because of the stigma around BFRBs, in many cases, the question doesn't get asked. In standard sort of screening instruments for mental health problems, the question, do you sometimes pick or pull a bite at your hair skin or nails doesn't tend to exist. So we don't have kind of large-scale epidemiological evidence. So the best we've got is some relatively small-scale studies and often these sorts of studies are carried out in school populations or
我们有准确的数据吗？我们没有确切的数据。我们有一些数字。但不幸的是，由于围绕 BFRB 的污名化，在许多情况下，人们根本不会问这个问题。在标准的心理健康问题筛查工具中，通常不存在“你是否有时会抠、拔或咬你的头发、皮肤或指甲”这个问题。所以我们没有大规模的流行病学证据。我们所能得到的最好数据是一些相对小规模的研究，而且这些研究通常是在学校人群或
college populations. But nevertheless, the best evidence suggests that about 5% or one in 20 people struggle with problematic levels of picking and pulling and biting. But the numbers of people who actually engage in the behavior at all, nail biting, hair pulling, skin picking at a level that isn't problematic is much higher. It's probably maybe half of us or maybe even all of us to a certain extent. Sure. Well, Dr. Mackay, you've lived with trichotillomania since childhood, but you only began studying it and speaking about that a few years ago. Can you tell us about your experience and why you decided to start talking about it now? Yeah, thank you. The experience of living with a body focused repetitive behavior for me
大学人群中进行的。尽管如此，最好的证据表明，大约 5% 或 1/20 的人正在与问题级别的抠、拔和咬行为作斗争。但是，实际上参与这些行为（咬指甲、拔毛、抠皮）且程度并不严重的人数要高得多。可能有一半人，甚至在某种程度上我们所有人都会这样做。当然。麦凯博士，你从小就患有拔毛癖，但直到几年前你才开始研究它并谈论它。你能告诉我们你的经历以及为什么你现在决定开始谈论它吗？是的，谢谢。对我来说，患有以身体为中心的重复性行为的经历
was one of hiding. And the biggest problem that I experienced for 40 years of living with hair pulling disorder was the amount of shame that I carried around about these behaviors. unfortunately because they're so little understood and so stigmatised, the general understanding of these behaviours is that we should be able to control them and we're just told to stop it. And that's by our families and our loved ones, but also by our doctors and the people who are there to care for us. And so when nobody has any good understanding or knowledge of these behaviours
就是一种隐藏。在我患有拔毛障碍的 40 年里，我经历的最大问题是我对这些行为所背负的羞耻感。不幸的是，由于人们对这些行为知之甚少且受到污名化，人们普遍认为我们应该能够控制它们，只是被告知“停止”。这不仅来自我们的家人和亲人，也来自我们的医生和照顾我们的人。所以当没有人对这些行为有很好的理解或知识，
and you can't control it, unfortunately that can set up a kind of chronic shape, spiral where you just think that you're fundamentally flawed. And even though I was, you know, on the surface a successful person, I managed to do some good science around all sorts of different diseases and disorders, it literally didn't cross my mind that I could apply some of this knowledge to the disorder that I'd been carrying around all my life, because shame has such a powerful, dampening effect on the way that we think. And so I got to, I got to, to, you know, menopause and the age of 50 where joyfully the great news is that you stop caring as much about what other people think of you. And it started to emerge for me that I
而你又无法控制它时，不幸的是，这会形成一种慢性的羞耻螺旋，让你觉得自己从根本上是有缺陷的。尽管我表面上是一个成功的人，我在各种疾病和障碍方面做了一些不错的研究，但我从未想过可以将这些知识应用到我一生都背负的障碍上，因为羞耻感对我们的思维方式有如此强大的抑制作用。所以我到了 50 岁，进入了更年期，令人高兴的是，好消息是你不再那么在意别人怎么看你了。我开始意识到我
could put these 30 years of neuroscience and 40 years of this disorder together and maybe do something useful with that. BFRBs used to be classified as impulse control disorders, but they're now grouped under obsessive compulsive disorders in the DSM, the diagnostic. statistical manual used by psychologists and physicians. So are these behaviors a form of OCD? How do they differ from and overlap with other disorders? I mean, are they related to things like Tourette's syndrome, for example? Sure. Great question. You know, it's tough because I wish we could have a separate category for BFRBs. It would be so nice. And we really advocated for that in the last iteration of the DSM. And unfortunately, that didn't happen. It really didn't fit in impulse control disorders.
可以将这 30 年的神经科学研究和 40 年的这种障碍结合起来，也许能用它做点有用的事情。BFRB 过去被归类为冲动控制障碍，但现在在 DSM（心理学家和医生使用的精神疾病诊断与统计手册）中被归类为强迫症。那么这些行为是强迫症的一种形式吗？它们与其他障碍有何不同和重叠？例如，它们与妥瑞氏症有关吗？当然。好问题。这很棘手，因为我希望我们能为 BFRB 设立一个单独的类别。那会很好。我们在上一版 DSM 中确实为此进行了倡导。但不幸的是，这没有实现。它确实不适合冲动控制障碍。
For some people, it does. For some people, it feels quite impulsive. But it didn't really fit with some of the other disorders that are listed in there. It doesn't 100% fit with OCD, although it is a repetitive behavior that is unwanted. They're very different. They're more like distant cousins, I think, but a lot of people assume they have OCD when they have a BFRB, and so we have to explain that they are quite different. So other than the fact that they are repetitive unwanted behaviors, and then this kind of ends the similarities, OCD people engage in repetitive behaviors because they feel like something bad will happen if they don't. This is very different from a BFRB where people, DFRB is a really more egosistic.
对某些人来说，它确实感觉很冲动。但它并不真正适合其中列出的其他障碍。它并不完全符合强迫症，尽管它是一种不想要的重复性行为。它们非常不同。我认为它们更像是远房表亲，但很多人在患有 BFRB 时会认为自己患有强迫症，所以我们必须解释它们是非常不同的。除了它们是重复的、不想要的行为之外，相似之处就到此为止了。强迫症患者进行重复行为是因为他们觉得如果不这样做，就会发生坏事。这与 BFRB 非常不同，BFRB 对人们来说是自我协调的，
tonic, which means that someone wants to engage in them. I liken it more, too, if you have a love of chocolate. You know, chocolate is really good until you have too much, right? And so, so it's more of an egosentonic, it kind of something that people want to do, whereas handwashing is something people hate doing that they feel compelled to do it. The medications for OCD do not across the board work for BFRBs. So that's a big difference. And then another difference is the treatments. And are, you know, there's some overlap, but there's also some real big differences. And what we don't want is for people to feel like medication doesn't work and treatment doesn't work. And maybe I could just add that as somebody who sort of come into the field relatively recently
这意味着有人想要参与其中。我更倾向于将其比作如果你热爱巧克力。你知道，巧克力很好，直到你吃得太多，对吧？所以它更像是一种自我协调，是人们想要做的事情，而洗手是人们讨厌做但觉得被迫去做的事情。强迫症的药物并不普遍适用于 BFRB。这是一个很大的区别。另一个区别是治疗方法。虽然有一些重叠，但也有很大的不同。我们不希望人们觉得药物无效、治疗无效。也许我可以补充一点，作为一个相对近期才进入该领域
and lived with these behaviors my whole life, what I observe is that BFRBs often get swept under the carpet of other disorders. So we've talked about OCD. We also talked a little bit about self-harm, and I regularly get asked about the relationship with those two. But they're also assumed to be a symptom of anxiety. And these days, more and more, there seem to be a symptom of neurodivergent conditions. So they seem to be more prevalent in ADHD and in autism, and they're thought of differently in those disorders. So what I observe is that these behaviours, which I think of us being a kind of motor symptom of distress quite broadly defined, get swept under the carpet of other disorders that people happen to know a bit more about.
并一生都带着这些行为的人，我观察到 BFRB 经常被掩盖在其他障碍之下。我们谈到了强迫症。我们也谈到了一点自残，我经常被问及这两者之间的关系。但它们也被认为是焦虑症的症状。如今，它们似乎越来越多地成为神经多样性疾病的症状。所以它们在多动症和自闭症中似乎更普遍，在这些障碍中被以不同的方式看待。所以我观察到，这些我认为是广泛定义的痛苦的运动症状的行为，被掩盖在人们碰巧了解更多一点的其他障碍之下。
And it's kind of part of the stigma that we need to reduce by thinking of them as quite distinct really from these other things so that we can find the ways to help people manage most effectively. Do BFRBs run in families? Is there, do we know whether there's any kind of a genetic? component here? We have looked at twin studies, and we do see that there is a higher concordance rate among twins.
这是我们需要减少的污名化的一部分，我们需要将它们视为与这些其他事物截然不同的东西，以便我们能够找到帮助人们最有效地管理它们的方法。BFRB 会在家族中遗传吗？我们是否知道这里是否有某种遗传成分？我们研究过双胞胎研究，确实发现双胞胎之间的共患率更高。
And we do see a higher concordance rate in families of people with BFRBs. Now, if a mother pulls her hair, it doesn't mean the child is necessarily more likely to pull hair. They might bite their nails or pick their bites or excoriate their acne. but we do see that BFRBs tend to run in families, but we don't have clinical data. We have some genetics data, but not enough. You need hundreds of thousands of people in a genetic database in order to really understand, from an empirical standpoint, yes, there is a genetic marker that will predict this,
我们也确实看到 BFRB 患者的家庭中存在更高的共患率。现在，如果母亲拔头发，并不意味着孩子一定更有可能拔头发。他们可能会咬指甲、抠痘痘或抓挠痤疮。但我们确实看到 BFRB 有在家族中遗传的倾向，但我们没有临床数据。我们有一些遗传学数据，但还不够。你需要遗传数据库中有成千上万的人才能真正从经验角度理解，是的，有一个遗传标记可以预测这一点，
but we do see it run in families quite often. Do we know what's happening in the brains of people when they're engaging in BFRBs? Well, there's all sorts of things happening in the brain of people while they're engaging in BFRBs. The way that I like to think about these behaviors from kind of first principles is that these are normal grooming behaviors. So grooming is a normal function of being a primate. grooming evolved as a way to take care of our body surface. It's a way to keep ourselves clean and free of parasites, etc. But in many animals, these grooming type behaviours, over hundreds of thousands of years of evolution,
但我们确实经常看到它在家族中遗传。我们知道人们在进行 BFRB 时大脑中发生了什么吗？嗯，人们在进行 BFRB 时大脑中发生了各种各样的事情。我喜欢从基本原则的角度来思考这些行为，即它们是正常的梳理行为。梳理是灵长类动物的一种正常功能。梳理进化为一种照顾我们身体表面的方式。这是一种保持自身清洁、无寄生虫等的方法。但在许多动物中，这些梳理类型的行为，经过数十万年的进化，
acquired additional functions. And the interesting thing about primates, and of course we are primates, is that the additional function that these grooming behaviours seem to have taken on is emotion regulations. So we pick, we are more likely to touch our faces or twirl our hair or do all sorts of body focus, repetitive things when we are trying to either calm our nerves down from being in a state of over-arousal, like being anxious, but also being overexcited. So any kind of state of over-arousal increases urges to pick and pull and bite to sort of calm ourselves down. But we can also find ourselves experiencing urges when we're understimulated. So often people with BFRBs talk about doing it when
获得了额外的功能。关于灵长类动物（当然我们也是灵长类动物）有趣的一点是，这些梳理行为似乎承担的额外功能是情绪调节。所以当我们试图通过处于过度唤醒状态（如焦虑，但也包括过度兴奋）来平静神经时，我们更有可能触摸脸部、卷头发或做各种以身体为中心的重复性动作。因此，任何形式的过度唤醒状态都会增加抠、拔和咬的冲动，以使自己平静下来。但我们也可能在刺激不足时体验到冲动。所以患有 BFRB 的人经常谈论在
they're bored. They're not doing anything else. They're not particularly, they're certainly not feeling particularly anxious, but it's a way of kind of giving our body some input when we're feeling understimulated. So this sort of emotion regulation function is something that primates acquired, and of course we're no different. So I tend to think that it's not, we're not looking for an area of brain that's kind of gone wrong. We're needing to understand multiple systems in the brain and how they interact with each other that gives rise to these behaviors. And I think that that's, as I say, there's actually a lot known about this in the animal literature that we haven't quite translated over into our understanding of these behaviors in humans.
他们感到无聊时做这些事。他们没有做其他任何事情。他们并不特别，当然也没有感到特别焦虑，但这是一种在我们感到刺激不足时给身体提供一些输入的方式。所以这种情绪调节功能是灵长类动物获得的一种功能，当然我们也不例外。所以我倾向于认为，我们并不是在寻找大脑中某个“出错”的区域。我们需要了解大脑中的多个系统以及它们如何相互作用从而产生这些行为。我认为，正如我所说，动物文献中实际上有很多关于这方面的知识，我们还没有完全将其转化为我们对人类这些行为的理解。
We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk about treatments for Trichotillomania and other BFRBs. It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay.
我们要休息一下。回来后，我们将讨论拔毛癖和其他 BFRB 的治疗方法。现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务扩展很快。为了保持花蜜流动，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的电话套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢繁忙时，我的连接依然强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元。这真是一个不会错过的优惠。
Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees. GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49.
立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。Google Fi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不受数据流量降速限制。你的夏天从家得宝的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四头燃气烤架开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅招待客人，仅需 49 美元。
This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. Well, let's talk about treatment because I know that there are some ways of helping people who have BFRBs. So Dr. Moutan, Odom, when someone comes to you for treatment, where do you start? So great question. I think it's important to think about these behaviors as very complex. And so when we approach a person, we have to think about that we can't make any assumptions. Just because they're pulling hair or picking skin, we don't want to assume any.
这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。好了，让我们谈谈治疗，因为我知道有一些方法可以帮助患有 BFRB 的人。所以穆顿-奥多姆博士，当有人来找你治疗时，你从哪里开始？这是一个很好的问题。我认为将这些行为视为非常复杂是很重要的。所以当我们接触一个人时，我们必须考虑到我们不能做任何假设。仅仅因为他们在拔头发或抠皮肤，我们不想做任何假设。
So really looking at their internal world, how they regulate their emotional system, how is their distress tolerance, how impulsive are they? Are they reward seeking? Are they more driven by positive reinforcement or negative reinforcement, which means are they seeking a reward? Are they kind of going away from a negative? Are they perfectionistic? Are they trying to get this eyebrow to match, that eyebrow, which sometimes the cognitive has a
所以要真正审视他们的内心世界，他们如何调节情绪系统，他们的痛苦承受能力如何，他们有多冲动？他们是寻求奖励吗？他们更多是被正强化还是负强化驱动，这意味着他们是在寻求奖励吗？他们是在远离负面事物吗？他们是完美主义者吗？他们是否试图让这边的眉毛和那边的眉毛匹配，这有时在认知上有一种
little more of an obsessional feel to it. So we want to understand their beliefs and their assumptions and their goals. Sometimes there are goals. I feel very efficient and goal directed in my behavior and I want to achieve a certain outcome. And so we want to look at cognitive one. And we also want to look at the sensory system and how much is this person regulated or attempting to regulate their sensory nervous system? And so, we also want to look at external things. Where is it happening? When is it happening? Are there things in the environment or in that person's external world that would make the behavior more likely to happen in a given moment? For example, if I go into the restroom, but it's in the morning
更强迫的感觉。所以我们想了解他们的信念、假设和目标。有时确实有目标。我觉得我的行为非常高效且目标明确，我想达到某种结果。所以我们想看看认知方面。我们也想看看感觉系统，这个人调节或试图调节其感觉神经系统的程度如何？因此，我们也想看看外部事物。它在哪里发生？什么时候发生？环境中或那个人的外部世界中是否有东西会使这种行为在特定时刻更有可能发生？例如，如果我走进洗手间，但那是早上，
and the lights are low, I may be able to get in, brush my teeth, get out. But in the evening, when the lights are brighter, I've had a long day. I'm emotionally dysregulated or I'm I'm sensory overwhelmed. No one's around. I have more time. There's a variety of external factors that also play in. So a good approach is to ask a lot of questions about what in this person's internal and external world make that behavior more or less likely to happen. And then we start to build a treatment plan based on that.
灯光很暗，我可能进去刷个牙就出来了。但在晚上，当灯光更亮时，我度过了漫长的一天。我情绪失调或感觉超负荷。周围没人。我有更多时间。还有各种各样的外部因素也在起作用。所以一个好的方法是询问很多关于这个人的内心和外部世界中什么使这种行为更有可能或更不可能发生的问题。然后我们开始据此制定治疗计划。
It's also not about making urges disappear. If I could take away a person's urges, I would be a rich woman. But so far, we don't have anything that will do that. So it's about how are we going to manage urges when they come? And not even everyone experiences urges, but whatever the precipitating environment events, internal events, external events are that make this behavior more likely to happen. When those things are at play, how am I going to manage that? We spend a lot of time in the beginning, as Claire talks so brilliantly about, is really undoing shame.
这也不是要让冲动消失。如果我能消除一个人的冲动，我就会成为一个富有的女人。但到目前为止，我们还没有任何东西可以做到这一点。所以关键在于当冲动来临时我们该如何管理？甚至不是每个人都会经历冲动，但无论是什么引发环境事件、内部事件、外部事件使这种行为更有可能发生。当这些事情在起作用时，我该如何管理？我们在开始时花了很多时间，正如克莱尔如此精彩地谈到的那样，是真正消除羞耻感。
So educating a person, helping them realize these are not strange, weird, odd behaviors. These are human behaviors. And starting that process of undoing shame, which is a constant process. It's not just a session. It is throughout the entire treatment process. And sometimes involves helping them connect with other people. which is such an important piece of treatment is to know, I am not alone. Other really amazing people engage in this behavior.
所以教育一个人，帮助他们意识到这些不是奇怪、怪异、古怪的行为。这些是人类的行为。并开始那个消除羞耻的过程，这是一个持续的过程。这不仅仅是一次会话。它贯穿于整个治疗过程。有时还涉及帮助他们与其他人建立联系，这是治疗中非常重要的一部分，即知道：我并不孤单。其他非常了不起的人也会有这种行为。
That's why Claire's work is so important. Here is a very accomplished, highly intelligent, beautiful human being, and she pulls out her hair. You know, and so what's the shame in that, right? So it's a process, it's a journey, we're on it together. It's collaborative. And it's sort of, I use diet and exercise a lot to, as an example. with BFRBs because we all have been at the point where we wanted to change our habits. We wanted to lose weight, say, we want to get healthier.
这就是为什么克莱尔的工作如此重要。这是一个非常有成就、高度聪明、美丽的人，她会拔掉自己的头发。你知道，那有什么可羞耻的呢，对吧？所以这是一个过程，这是一段旅程，我们在一起。它是协作的。我经常用饮食和锻炼作为一个例子，
We want to stop eating junk food. But we still do it, you know, and I can buy the tennis shoes and I can buy all the outfits. I can even join the gym, but it doesn't mean I'm going to go. It doesn't mean I'm going to engage. And so really, it's about helping a person engage in the process and be ready to make those changes. and that's why we do so much training with professionals because if they don't understand that and they read an article about how to do treatment and they go in and use this and do this, it will fail.
因为我们都曾处于想要改变习惯的阶段。我们想减肥，比如说，我们想变得更健康。我们想停止吃垃圾食品。但我们仍然会这样做，你知道，我可以买网球鞋，我可以买所有的装备。我甚至可以加入健身房，但这并不意味着我会去。这并不意味着我会参与。所以真正重要的是帮助一个人参与到这个过程中，并准备好做出这些改变。这就是为什么我们对专业人士进行如此多的培训，因为如果他们不理解这一点，他们读了一篇关于如何进行治疗的文章，然后进去使用它，它就会失败。
And then, you know, patients are frustrated, therapists are frustrated. Everybody walks away and says treatment doesn't work. And that is not true. Treatment does work if it's done right. Well, Dr. Mikhail, let me ask you, what do you do to keep your hair pulling at bay? I mean, do you have techniques? Are there triggers you try to avoid? Have you undergone therapy? How have you managed? I have. I've had, when I was younger, when I was in my 30s, I had therapy, which was much more behavioral. So some of those elements that Suzanne described, so thinking about the situation and the awareness, etc.
然后，你知道，病人感到沮丧，治疗师感到沮丧。每个人都走开说治疗无效。那是不对的。如果做得正确，治疗是有效的。好吧，麦凯博士，让我问你，你做什么来控制你的拔毛行为？我的意思是，你有技巧吗？有没有你试图避免的诱因？你接受过治疗吗？你是如何管理的？我有。我年轻时，30 多岁时，接受过治疗，那更偏向行为疗法。所以苏珊描述的一些元素，比如思考情况和意识等。
But it was kind of missing the thing that I now know was critical for me, which was compassion. So living with chronic shame, I should first say that I didn't even really know the extent of the shame that I was living in because it was just normal for me. And so it took a bit of therapy and that preparation work that Suzanne's talking about to get to the point where I even realized that actually the biggest problem I lived with is not pulling out my hair. It's the shame that I'm carrying around. And the antidote to shame, the thing that really works for me is compassion. Now, compassion is a word that sounds kind of fluffy and gentle and easy. We use it in common parlance. It's actually a really important skill that you need to learn and you need to practice
但它缺少了我现在知道对我来说至关重要的东西，那就是同情心。所以带着长期的羞耻感生活，我首先应该说，我甚至没有真正意识到我生活在其中的羞耻程度，因为这对我来说很正常。所以需要一点治疗和苏珊谈到的那种准备工作，才能让我意识到，实际上我生活中的最大问题不是拔头发。而是我背负的羞耻感。而羞耻的解药，真正对我有效的东西是同情心。现在，同情心是一个听起来有点轻飘飘、温柔且容易的词。我们在日常用语中使用它。它实际上是一项你必须学习并必须练习的重要技能，
in order to be good at it. And so learning compassion, learning self-compassion is a process. I'm still in it. But for me, what that means is using my brain, using my neuroscience, brain. So I've just spent the last two years really trying to understand living with urges to pick and pull and bite from a number of different angles. And I've gone into areas of science. I knew nothing about before. And I'm learning all the time. For me, that's what compassion is. It's kind of, it's throwing away those awful, I call them dementors of shame that
为了擅长它。所以学习同情心，学习自我同情是一个过程。我还在其中。但对我来说，这意味着使用我的大脑，使用我的神经科学大脑。所以我过去两年一直在努力尝试从多个不同的角度理解与抠、拔和咬的冲动共存。我进入了我以前一无所知的科学领域。我一直在学习。对我来说，这就是同情心。这是一种抛弃那些可怕的、我称之为羞耻摄魂怪的东西，
are swirling around your head. Otherwise, you're stupid, you're weak, you're ugly, you've got no self-control, you've got no willpower. These are things that people would be. FRB, say to themselves all the time and learning how to dial those down so that you can ask yourself, hmm, I wonder why my urges are particularly tricky today and asking in a much more gentle, curious, compassionate way rather than a, oh, God, I'm so stupid, I've done it again, etc. So compassion is absolutely the top of the list of things for me that made the difference. I want to ask about the influence of social media, you know, that's had an impact on a lot of disorders that people have. Is it helping or harming people with BFRBs? Do you have any opinion around that?
它们在你的脑海中盘旋。否则，你很蠢，你很软弱，你很丑，你没有自控力，你没有意志力。这些是 BFRB 患者一直对自己说的话，学习如何调低这些声音，这样你就可以问自己，嗯，我想知道为什么我的冲动今天特别棘手，并以一种更温和、好奇、富有同情心的方式询问，而不是“哦，天哪，我太蠢了，我又做了”等等。所以同情心绝对是我清单上最重要的东西，它带来了改变。我想问一下社交媒体的影响，你知道，这对人们患的许多疾病都有影响。它是在帮助还是在伤害 BFRB 患者？你对此有什么看法吗？
I don't think there's any research to say one way or the other. I think we all know that social media is doing a lot of harm, especially to young women and their sense of self and their confidence. But I also imagine a lot of good. I know there's some quite a few. influencers and people who are utilizing social media in a positive way to establish community, to be a leader in this space where people feel alone, people feel ashamed. And as somebody who lives with the BFRB, I can tell you that as I started to think that maybe I could come out about my BFRB, social media was the first place I could take my baby steps. And actually, it's kind of now old tech, but nevertheless, Facebook support groups are fantastic for this sort of thing because you can be anonymous. You can find your community.
我不认为有任何研究能说明是好是坏。我想我们都知道社交媒体正在造成很多伤害，尤其是对年轻女性的自我意识和自信心。但我也想象它有很多好处。我知道有不少网红和人们正在以积极的方式利用社交媒体来建立社区，成为这个领域的领导者，让人们感到不再孤单，不再羞耻。作为一个患有 BFRB 的人，我可以告诉你，当我开始想也许我可以公开我的 BFRB 时，社交媒体是我迈出第一步的地方。实际上，它现在算是旧技术了，但尽管如此，Facebook 支持小组对于这类事情非常棒，因为你可以匿名。你可以找到你的社区。
You can find community to people who know exactly what you're going through and you can share hints and tips and things that you've found. And actually, they are enormously helpful when you're, you know, when you're still not feeling able to say anything out loud to the real people in your lives. you can actually start to find community online and start to get that deshaming process underway by just being part of a community. And yeah, so I would say that exactly as Suzanne said, it's a bit of both, but for those of us who are wanting to reach out and find people,
你可以找到了解你正在经历什么的社区，你可以分享提示、技巧和你发现的东西。实际上，当你仍然觉得无法对现实生活中的人说出任何话时，它们是非常有帮助的。你实际上可以开始在网上找到社区，并通过成为社区的一部分开始那个消除羞耻的过程。是的，所以我会说，正如苏珊所说，这既有好处也有坏处，但对于我们这些想要接触并找到同伴的人来说，
there isn't really a safer way to do it than through the internet. Of course, I'm old enough that when I started to struggle with my head, pulling problems. There was nowhere for me, all my parents to go for any information. It was before Trichotillomania was in the DSM. There was no Google. There was no internet. And so you are completely alone with that. So I guess coming from that generation, I see huge benefits of being able to find other people through the internet. That's so true. The only caution I would have because I imagine there are many parents as your listeners.
没有比通过互联网更安全的方法了。当然，我年纪够大，当我开始与拔毛问题作斗争时。我和我的父母没有任何地方可以获取任何信息。那是在拔毛癖进入 DSM 之前。没有谷歌。没有互联网。所以你完全孤单。所以我猜来自那一代人，我看到了通过互联网找到其他人的巨大好处。这太对了。我唯一的提醒是因为我想有很多家长作为你的听众。
And oftentimes the people who post online and on Reddit and on these forums are people who are very frustrated and angry. And so I would encourage parents to go to reliable sources to get their information because a lot of times people will come in and they will have very, very wrong information that they got on the Internet. So that's just a caution to parents to be very careful where they're reading their information. So speaking of those parents who may be listening, I mean, if somebody thinks that their child is experiencing some kind of a BFRB, what should they do? Where should they go? Well, there are a lot of resources out there, the TLC Foundation for BFRBs being one of them. There are some other BFRB change makers. There are other nonprofit groups out there, the International OCD Foundation.
而且通常在网上和 Reddit 以及这些论坛上发帖的人是非常沮丧和愤怒的人。所以我鼓励家长去可靠的来源获取信息。因为很多时候人们会进来，他们会带着从互联网上得到的非常非常错误的信息。所以这只是给家长的提醒，在阅读信息时要非常小心。那么说到那些可能正在收听的家长，如果有人认为他们的孩子正在经历某种 BFRB，他们应该怎么做？他们应该去哪里？嗯，有很多资源，TLC BFRB 基金会就是其中之一。还有一些其他的 BFRB 变革者。还有其他非营利组织，国际强迫症基金会。
The BFRB, UK, Ireland has a group that's representing Europe. Claire is very involved in Oxford and with that group. So there are communities in the world and they're growing. We're finding communities in Mexico and other parts of Europe and Asia and Canada. So I think getting good information. And then possibly attending an event, whether it's an online group or an in-person event, is really helpful. But it's so important to get good information from the beginning. And parents, I will have to say, need as much support as the kiddos and sometimes more.
英国和爱尔兰的 BFRB 有一个代表欧洲的团体。克莱尔在牛津和那个团体中非常活跃。所以世界上有社区，而且它们正在成长。我们在墨西哥、欧洲其他地区、亚洲和加拿大都发现了社区。所以我认为获取好的信息很重要。然后可能参加一个活动，无论是线上小组还是线下活动，都非常有帮助。但从一开始就获得好的信息非常重要。而且我必须说，家长和孩子们一样需要支持，有时甚至更多。
Depending on the age of the child, they might not really care at this point yet. But how they are treated by their parents matters a lot. And so how parents respond is critical to the shame, the development of identity, self-esteem, confidence. And I always tell parents, you know, what we want to do is what is best for your child in the long run. And we want to focus on the things that are important about your child. And their hair and their skin is not that. And so it's helping them to sort of shift the focus to what's really important. It's hard for parents, though, because their role as a parent is to help their child,
根据孩子的年龄，他们现在可能还不太在意。但他们被父母对待的方式非常重要。所以父母的反应对羞耻感、身份认同、自尊、自信的发展至关重要。我总是告诉家长，你知道，我们想做的是从长远来看对你的孩子最好的事情。我们想关注关于你孩子的重要事情。而他们的头发和皮肤不是重点。所以这是帮助他们将注意力转移到真正重要的事情上。不过这对家长来说很难，因为他们作为家长的角色是帮助孩子，
and they see their child doing this really scary thing that they don't understand if they did not engage in that particular BFRB. Now, oftentimes the parents will have a BFRB, but it maybe doesn't bother them as much, or it's been annoying, but not to the point where it's caused bald spots. But we'll see parents who engage in nail-bidding or some other BFRB and helping them to develop that compassion for their child. is critical for them to change their approach. I completely agree. And exactly as you said, Suzanne, helping parents to understand
他们看到孩子在做这种非常可怕的事情，如果他们自己没有参与那种特定的 BFRB，他们就不理解。现在，通常父母也会有 BFRB，但它可能不会困扰他们那么多，或者它一直很烦人，但没有到导致秃斑的地步。但我们会看到参与咬指甲或其他 BFRB 的父母，帮助他们培养对孩子的同情心，对他们改变方法至关重要。我完全同意。正如你所说，苏珊，帮助家长理解
that their feelings around their child's BFRB are big, strong, powerful feelings that need to be understood, they need to be validated, and they need to be supported separate from helping their child with their BFRB. And one more thing I would say about that is it came from an,
他们对孩子 BFRB 的感受是巨大、强烈、有力的感受，需要被理解、被认可，并且需要得到支持，这与帮助孩子处理他们的 BFRB 是分开的。关于这一点，我还要再说一件事，它来自一个
event that I did just last night with another group of Suzanne's colleagues, where a parent asked the question, how can I help my child live without shame? And I was absolutely delighted to hear that question instead of the question I usually hear, which is, how can I help my child stop pulling out their hair or picking at their skin? Because that's the right question. The thing that you don't want is for your child to grow up with chronic shame. And that's much more important than whether or not they've got a full head of hair and some lesions on their skin. So for both of you, what are the big questions you want to answer? What are you working on now?
我昨晚刚和苏珊的另一组同事参加的活动，一位家长问了一个问题：“我怎样才能帮助我的孩子在没有羞耻感的情况下生活？”我非常高兴听到这个问题，而不是我通常听到的问题，即“我怎样才能帮助我的孩子停止拔头发或抠皮肤？”因为那是正确的问题。你最不希望的是你的孩子在长期的羞耻感中长大。这比他们是否有一头浓密的头发和皮肤上是否有病变要重要得多。所以对你们俩来说，你们想回答的大问题是什么？你们现在在研究什么？
Dr. Mouton, Odom, you want to go first? Well, I'm working on, there was a big initiative pre-COVID by the TLC Foundation. A lot of data were gathered. 250 people had lots and lots and lots of tests, genetic tests, brain scans, etc. and we're waiting through those data. But I have really done a deep dive and trying to reimagine how we think about people. And we're writing up a paper that I'm super, super excited about. I think everyone gets a little bit siloed with BFRBs and they only see, you know, one part of the elephant, if you will.
穆顿-奥多姆博士，你想先说吗？嗯，我正在研究，TLC 基金会在新冠疫情前有一个大计划。收集了大量数据。250 人进行了大量测试、基因测试、脑部扫描等。我们正在梳理这些数据。但我确实进行了深入研究，试图重新构想我们如何看待人们。我们正在写一篇我非常非常兴奋的论文。我认为每个人在 BFRB 方面都有点孤立，他们只看到了大象的一部分，如果你愿意的话。
And everyone just focuses on that part. and I think we all need to step back and see the whole picture. The issue with treatment has always been, everyone's trying to lump people into your this or you're that or you're this or you're that. And sure enough, as soon as you do that, someone walks in the door and they don't fit in either of those buckets. And so we're really trying to step back and create a model that accounts for all presentations so that we can then approach that person with a path to treatment.
每个人都只关注那一部分。我认为我们都需要退后一步，从全局来看。治疗的问题一直在于，每个人都试图把人归类，说你是这种人，或者你是那种人。果不其然，一旦你这样做，就会有人走进来，而他们并不属于任何一个类别。所以我们真的在尝试退后一步，建立一个能够涵盖所有表现形式的模型，这样我们就能为那个人找到一条治疗途径。
But all of that said, we still have to do the foundational work of undoing shame and preparing the person for treatment. So coming up with a model that that involves all of that is what I'm super excited about and more to come. Dr. Mackay, what about you? Yeah. So, well, I've started quite a few new things off. And I'm going to talk about one of them in particular.
但话虽如此，我们仍然必须做基础工作，即消除羞耻感并为治疗做好准备。因此，能够提出一个包含所有这些因素的模型，让我感到非常兴奋，敬请期待。麦凯博士，你呢？是的。嗯，我已经开始了不少新项目。我打算特别谈谈其中一个。
I've talked quite a bit about shame and we've got quite a bit of. stuff going on about understanding how to conceptualise shame and how to help people with it. But actually, I'm going to talk about something a bit different, which is that I have developed a real interest in something which is regularly described as part of the phenomenology of VFRBs, which is that when we're picking and pulling and biting, we go into a kind of a trance like state. This is a kind of altered state of consciousness where you're not quite aware and not quite unaware and you become hyper-focused on the whatever it is that's your target, the hair, the skin, whatever your target is. And states of consciousness, of course, are things
我已经谈了很多关于羞耻感的话题，我们也做了很多关于如何概念化羞耻感以及如何帮助人们应对它的工作。但实际上，我要谈的是一些不同的东西，那就是我对一种经常被描述为身体聚焦重复行为（BFRB）现象学一部分的东西产生了浓厚的兴趣，即当我们抠、拔、咬时，我们会进入一种类似恍惚的状态。这是一种意识改变的状态，你处于一种既非完全清醒也非完全无意识的状态，你会对你的目标——无论是头发、皮肤还是其他任何目标——变得高度专注。当然，意识状态是人们感兴趣的事情。
that lots of people are interested in. And this state of consciousness, which might be a kind of something that's in between awake and asleep, where you're not quite awake and you're certainly not asleep, but you've gone, you're kind of dissociated, you're somewhere else. And you're still, you know, the telly's still on. You're still in the room. It's not like you're, it's not like a trauma-related dissociation. It's a different thing. And trying to, trying to understand exactly what that phenomenon is and how that then forms part of that package that Suzanne was talking about is really critical because in that trans like state, cognitive strategies don't stand a chance. They have no way in. You're not, I don't have access
很多人都对这种意识状态感兴趣。这种意识状态可能介于清醒和睡眠之间，你并没有完全清醒，当然也没有睡着，但你已经进入了一种解离状态，仿佛身处别处。你仍然知道电视开着，你仍然在房间里。这不像那种与创伤相关的解离，这是另一回事。试图准确理解这种现象是什么，以及它如何构成苏珊所说的那一部分，是非常关键的，因为在这种恍惚状态下，认知策略根本不起作用。它们没有切入点。我无法获取
to my cognitive strategies when I'm in that translike state. So I have kind of very early ideas that actually we need to be thinking a little bit more about sensory strategies and breathing work to sort of help you snap out of that kind of that state that you get into. And so it's been described many times the state, but it's not really been explored. So that's one of the things I'm excited about. Wow. Well, I want to thank you both. This has been absolutely fascinating.
当我在那种恍惚状态下时，我无法使用我的认知策略。所以我有一些非常初步的想法，实际上我们需要更多地考虑感官策略和呼吸练习，以帮助你从那种状态中跳出来。这种状态已经被描述过很多次，但并没有真正被深入探索过。所以这是我感到兴奋的事情之一。哇。好吧，我要感谢你们两位。这绝对太迷人了。
And I think it's been very helpful for our listeners to learn and also to help destigmatize something that we know is, fairly common. So thank you. Thank you for having us. It's great to share you like on BFRBs. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof Psychology.org or on Apple, YouTube, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我认为这对我们的听众来说非常有帮助，不仅能让他们学习，还能帮助消除我们所知的相当普遍的某种污名。所以谢谢你们。谢谢你们邀请我们。很高兴能分享关于BFRB的见解。您可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、YouTube、Spotify或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的节目有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。感谢您的收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。